I'm going to show you some math ideas
that are pretty common when solving
physics problems at a bit of a higher
level so let's start at looking at an
example of multivariable calculus as
it's used in classical mechanics let's
say we have a spherical pendulum using
spherical coordinates we can write the
location of the mass using XYZ as
follows where owl is the fixed length of
the rod in a problem like this we might
be asked to find the equation of motion
through Lagrangian mechanics the first
step in doing that is to find the
kinetic energy of the system to find
kinetic energy we want to find 1/2 MV
squared where in this case the velocity
is a vector with three components in the
X Y & Z directions using a dot to
represent a derivative with respect to
time we need to find X dot y dot and Z
dot to find our velocity vector to
differentiate X with respect to time we
use a combination of the product rule
and the chain rule
since both Phi and theta our variables
that change with time the product rule
gives two terms and the chain rule gives
theta dot and Phi dot Z dot just
requires the chain rule a physics major
will become quite fast at this kind of
differentiation now let's look at some
vector calculus essential for electromag
if you want to find a magnetic field due
to a current you may use the bias of art
law the equation includes
and integral some constants and a cross
product between two vectors these
vectors are the length of current and
the location where the field is being
measured a cross product gives a third
vector that is at right angles to the
original two we want to this since
magnetic field flows at a 90-degree
angle to current flow as an example of
how to take the cross product say we
have two vectors a and B with components
in the x y&z directions take the cross
product of each term two components in
the same direction will have zero cross
product but X crossed with Y for example
will give said if the directions I'm
crossing appear in the sequence X Y Z X
Y then I know the resulting component
will be positive otherwise it will be
negative
here is our resultant vector the idea of
this video is just to give you a taste
of how math is used in physics so don't
worry too much about remembering the
details you'll be sure to encounter
these ideas as you go along